We've learned so far that BRCA1 exerts its
main effect by aiding the DNA repair machinery in
breast cells. But obviously there are a lot
of other factors, both genetic and environmental that contribute
to one, the overall mutation rate in a
cell as well as the cell's ability to repair
those mutations. Other environmental factors that generally effect
DNA mutation and repair could be things like UV
exposure, particularly for tissues in your skin, or
cigarette smoking, particularly affecting tissues in your lungs.
These can increase the chance for DNA damage.
Thus making it more likely that a repair
may not happen. And there are even more
genetic and non-genetic factors that contribute to risk
in far less well understood ways. For most
women who develop breast cancer, it's due to
a combination of many of these different environmental and genetic
factors. Let's say that we have two women who've been
analyzed for eight genetic factors associated with risk for breast
cancer. At the end of the test we see that
they have same alleles for each of these eight genetic
factors. They both test same for each of those eight
alleles and thus they have the same calculated risk for
breast cancer. But one of the women goes onto develop
breast cancer, whereas the other one does not. I want you to tell me how
or why this is even possible. They had the same genetic makeup for these eight
genetic factors. They had the same calculated
genetic risk but one got breast cancer and
the other one didn't. Go ahead and put your answer in the text box here.